what surprised me the most for sure was
that she was part of killing Brice I
mean I was surprised that she didn't do
it herself surprisingly like I wanted to
be the one that did the last push but
yeah I was cast of 13 reasons why is
weighing in on that shocking season
three finale spoiler alert it's Alex and
kinda Jessica who are responsible for
Bryce's death why are you here
he's with me I didn't know for the first
episode when we filmed the first episode
I didn't know but I found out maybe a
couple weeks into filming and I was like
I said I was mad that I wasn't the one
that did it
why not sleep under the stars and you
know meditate on how hard it is to get
the world to let you change just please
Justin Prentiss dishing on the final
moments that led to Bryce's death in
life don't keep doing anything does that
you you set me up yeah I think that's
even still in character for Bryce I
don't think it means that he hadn't
learned anything kind of on his journey
that he'd taken and up to that point I
think he was trying to seek out amends
in his own way and and and kind of what
that meant to him and how he felt he
could go about it and then obviously he
you know like in reaching either Jess
you know he was met with you know walls
rightfully so a lot of the time they
didn't really know where to go from
there so I don't know I think I don't
think his response to Alex I don't think
that nullifies what he had learned up at
that point emotionally how much he'd
grown I just think that Bryce's is
pushed to default back on his old
behavior in certain circumstances and
you see that with different characters
you see it a lot with Dempsey so even
though he can be loving and empathetic
towards you know one character perhaps
you know Ani or you know in some
instances his mother that doesn't mean
that he won't immediately default back
to to you know his his years of being
sort of the
alpha aggressor when provoked and I
think this is a moment where he's
definitely provoked he just got his ass
handed to him by Dempsey and this is
sort of his last kind of knife to the
guide I mean there's not much he can do
they're just lying helplessly there so
yeah i it was it was really interesting
I thought it was done really well I
think and I think it was it was an
interesting way to end it Annie's
revealing when and how he found out his
character was doomed York er showrunner
took me out to lunch before we came up
here to start filming season 3 so I knew
ahead of time there's a scene where she
and clay on II and clay are talking
about something mysterious that happened
to a character I'm like that's
suspicious and then York he emailed me
like 10 minutes later like let's grab
lunch yeah I know where this is going
and he's like hey sit down sit down
you're dead and I'm like but yet but
then you you know you sort of explain
kind of the arc of the season and I was
I was yeah I was looking forward to
showing a different side Bryce Bryce
wasn't the only season 3 death though
viewers also learned Monty died in
prison after being wrongfully blamed for
Bryce's death and of course Monty
struggle with his sexuality was a major
storyline it's a couple of different
things it's definitely the the jock
toxic masculine culture I don't think
it's easy for them or they feel like
they they can't come out under the
circumstances and then his his home life
you you can see right away his father is
a little bit I mean very close minded he
uses very inappropriate language and I
don't think he ever felt comfortable you
know at home even entertaining the idea
that he might be attracted to men I
think you see in the final in the final
episode his dad comes to visit him and
he's asking him about the assault with
Tyler and he says you know what are you
in an F word and you know in Monty's
mind he said you know he says what you
know maybe I am what if I was and is
that called you know kind of comes down
on it I mean I think you see right then
in there that it's just it's it's
there's so much more to Monty story than
then that meets the eye as for season
four here's what the cast is saying I
want to see something good happen to
Tony yeah
this but a lot of bad for everybody but
he kind of bears the weight of this
thing is the secret keeper has been
there for play and Tyler through some
bit immeasurably rough times so I'm just
hoping he gets a sliver of light and all
that darkness stand this thing but we'll
see yeah the same feeling for Jessica I
just hope that she's able to graduate
high school as a strong independent
woman who was able to move through the
world and not defined by her trauma well
I mean I would hope through season four
and whatever Monte's relationship is and
that season um that he would be able to
kind of resolve some of the issues or
come to peace with who he is as a human
being and maybe rest peacefully I guess
I don't know Brice's story I feel like
there's a nice bow on his storyline and
the audience doesn't want to probably
see much we've seen enough of brace yeah
I mean I think we laid it all out there
I think you know we got to see the full
side of him the first couple of seasons
we get to see the flip side of that I
think a little bit we get to see the the
other facet of Brice or at least him
trying to hone another
yeah I don't know I think I feel like
he's been pretty well explored I feel
like as an actor I feel relief in moving
forward with my life knowing that we
kind of put it all out there and
explored everything we can for the
character
[Music]